this is good day Las Vegas
now today is a very special day it's Dia
de los Muertos a day to honor and
remember loved ones who've passed on
with celebration and decoration so
excited to have Miguel Julio here in
studio of Miguel Julio Beauty and Kim
you're working with Miguel doing the
hair and our beautiful model Alondra
this morning now this is no easy task no
Miguel how long did this take about two
two and a half hours two and a half
hours so you were up very early this
morning this morning okay but I am a
professional so you've got it down he
knows what he's doing let's start with
the hair because the hair is important
the headpiece is important can how do
you do this how do you create this look
well Miguel made this intricate
headpiece and so what I had to do was a
headband and then he used some flowers
that he found at a local store and then
I pinned it on but the curls actually
are more kind of like wanded and kind of
bouncy and what I've done interior wise
is just kind of tease them out just to
spread them out to give them a little
life and a little bounce and we used a
fresh styling spray by pureology
volume is everything so little flat hair
amateurish
volume yes the idea is beauty right I
mean we are celebrating and honoring our
loved ones now let's talk about the
makeup itself that is so critical
um today is a very important day it's
not Halloween this is something special
yes it is special day to honor a little
history behind the day itself the day it
actually uh these come from the sugar
skulls that were made when the Spanish
actually came from oh my gosh somewhere
else I forgot but anyway for the Spanish
conquered Mexico they brought this uh
technique uh making little sugar skulls
out of a sugar paste okay and that's
what inspired this and then from there
the tradition there was a Le Katrina
animated uh Cartoon that was made and so
and that kind of got adopted into the
tradition as well and now we have these
beautiful sugar skull faces the colors
actually represent something which is
really cool
represents love okay the White and the
black represent mortality and passing on
and and so you've done such a beautiful
job with the creation here Alondra looks
beautiful is there a little bit of open
interpretation as far as the design
itself or is there something that you
should follow I would say follow
tradition for today especially so if I
kind of was when I was doing my research
for this like if you show up at a Day of
the Dead Festival which has a unicorn
they're gonna like blew you out like Boo
get out of here
it's got to be traditional okay that's
how we kind of look it up and if you
want to celebrate it today it can be an
extension of Halloween not technically
the same thing of course a little bit
different okay so starting with the
white I know it's a lengthy process
running out of time but we're going to
bring you back here at the end of the
show talk a little bit more about the
decoration Miguel Kim Alondra just
beautiful stay with us we're gonna have
a little more coming up and